we're trying to call attention to a
tremendous human rights abuse that is
being almost completely ignored and I
will be very brief uh I am Robert
Spencer from Jihad watch and uh
thanks we have a we have a full roster
of speakers here today and so I just
wanted to expand on a couple of things
that uh Pamela said earlier uh you all
know of course that the uh media is
spinning this as a uh an exercise in
hatred and islamophobia and that uh the
earlier conference that was held today
is claiming that uh we are blaming Islam
for something that has nothing to do
with Islam and Pamela has already
touched on this in uh saying that
pointing out that 91% of all honor
killings are done by Muslims and among
Muslims and that that is no accident it
is in a manual of Islamic law Reliance
of the traveler orik that is actually
certified by lar University which is the
foremost authority in Sunni Islam and
Sunni Muslims are 85 to 90% of all
Muslims worldwide and this Manual of
Islamic law is certified as being a
reliable guide to what Islam is and it
says in there that there is no
retaliation for a parent who kills a
child there is no
penalty not only that Jordan Syria
Palestinian Authority Iraq and elsewhere
if you kill somebody then then you have
the various uh kinds of punishments that
Prevail around the world but if you can
prove that it was an honor killing you
get off
lightly and in Jordan the Jordanian
Parliament actually several years ago
tried to stiffen penalties for honor
killings and it was Islamic clerics who
opposed this measure and ultimately
defeated it saying that it would weaken
the
family we have to face the facts that if
we're going to defend the human rights
of these girls who are threatened then
we have to face that this is an Islamic
problem and this does not mean that
every Muslim in the world is going to
kill his daughter but the justifications
for this practice are in Islamic law and
that is why 91% of honor killings take
place among Muslims and unless and until
we face that and unless and until we
call upon the Muslim Community in the
United States and worldwide to face it
more girls are going to
die and so it's all very well for the
Imam at the Islamic Center of America in
Dearborn to say well Pamela Geller is
the problem and she's spreading
islamophobia but what he is doing is
exactly what she said it was it is pro-
honor killing it is in defense of Honor
killing because by standing up against
those of us who were trying to call
attention to this barbarity and to end
it and making us into the problem he is
doing nothing but running interference
for Honor
murder and So Pro honor killing is
exactly the right term for those who
have come out in opposition to what
we're doing here
today this is not a problem that is of
stigmatizing individuals this is a
problem of a legal code that threatens
individuals